-James!
-Adam Sandler!
It is great to see you, bud.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Hi! Hey!
I love ya!
Nice to see you all!
-We love having you on the show.
Thank you so much
for being here, bud.
-I'm very excited.
-I want to -- I want to
congratulate you
because a week ago...
-Yes.
-...you received
the Mark Twain Prize.
-Yes. Yeah.
Isn't that wonderful?
[ Cheers and applause ]
-American Humor.
At the Kennedy Center.
That is a big deal, bud.
-Very good.
-And well deserved.
It was so awesome.
-Yes, I enjoyed it.
-Yeah, you did?
[ Laughter ]
-I grew up loving Mark Twain.
You read --
You read "Tom Sawyer," anybody?
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Yeah, yeah, yeah.
-I read it twice.
-Wow! Wow!
You liked it that much?
-I was like, "Something about
this guy's connecting with me."
-Yeah. No. Yeah,
It was a really great time.
-It was a star-studded night.
-Yes.
-Everybody was there.
I got a picture right here.
-Yeah.
-One of your buddies here.
-Who's that?
-Chris Rock.
-Oh, yes.
Young Chris Rock showing up.
-Chris Rock was in the house.
-Yeah.
Look at him! He looks good!
-He's unbelievable.
-He stays handsome.
-He's unbelie--
He is very, very handsome.
But everybody -- I mean --
-Yeah.
-Everybody was there.
-A bunch of my -- A bunch
of comedian friends came.
The Mark Twain thing is --
You want to show another one?
-Yeah. I dug out --
Another --
-I do. You felt it?
-Yeah. Yeah.
-I thought you'd be yearning --
yearning to move on.
-Itchy trigger finger?
[ Laughter ]
You felt me going over there?
-Yeah.
-No. I was gonna say.
I know Conan was there.
Judd Apatow was there.
Spade was funny.
-Yes.
-But then this one --
I thought this was
kind of a cool one.
-Yeah. One of my best friends
was there.
-Yeah, yeah. Wolf Blitzer.
-Wolf Blitzer and I, we went
to junior high school together.
[ Laughs ] No. No. I met --
I met him that night, man.
"The Blitz," I call him.
-The Blitz!
-Yeah.
-Yeah, he was --
-I was hanging out with a --
with a whole different
type of people.
-Yeah.
The whole night was great
and entertaining. Do --
You're a very humble guy.
You don't like
anyone talking about you.
-You don't want to sit there
and have people compliment you
and say you're good
and be in the room.
You like hearing that
when you're not in the room.
-Yeah, exactly.
-Like a friend calling you up
and saying,
"Hey, I was talking
to so-and-so.
He said good things about you."
-Yeah.
-You don't want to be there
hearing, like, "You know
what I like about you?"
And then you're like, "Oh, boy."
-You know who crushed?
Your wife, Jackie.
-My wife went on and did
a speech about me, everybody.
-Yeah.
-And she did -- she --
[ Cheers and applause ]
-She was amazing.
-She did great.
She talked for, I said,
four minutes,
and then she screamed eight.
-[ Laughs ]
That's not there. Yeah.
But, you know, they had a very
funny video that they showed.
Here's --
-No. What is this?
-This is good.
Now, this is Kenny Smith.
Oh, he's complimentary in it?
-NBA legend.
"Inside the NBA" analyst.
-He saying good things
about my game?
-Oh.
-Yeah.
-Oh, he said amazing things.
-Oh, I just can't wait
to see it.
-Oh, yeah, here's him
talking about your game.
-Yay.
-He is only a passer
at this stage in his career
with bad costuming
and whatever that -- Is that --
That's not even a costume.
Oh, he actually --
This is a real clip
of him actually playing.
I thought this was a movie set.
Who wears a polo
and long shorts?
Who plays basketball
with sunglasses on?
Listen to this.
If your dog
can steal the ball from you,
you're in the wrong sport,
ladies and gentlemen.
-That is ridiculous.
-What is he talking about?
-First of all,
I do love Kenny Smith,
and he -- they catch --
These are bad moments.
I have such a great game.
It's insane, everybody.
The dog got lucky.
It bit my ball.
[ Laughter ]
No, I don't --
I'm telling you.
I'm older now. I'm 56!
-What? No.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-I'm old, man!
-No, you're always young.
Forever young.
-Well, alright.
I'll pretend I'm young.
But, honestly, when
I'm on the court and it's --
I'm dribbling
and I see other guys on my team,
I never take the shot
because I'm like,
"He's better than me.
He's better than me."
Just --
That's why I look to pass.
Then whenever I go --
And somebody will say to me,
"Hey, start shooting more."
I'll be like,
"Yeah, he's right, he's right."
So then I take a shot and miss.
I go, "Didn't I tell you?"
-Yeah. Yeah.
You got to trust your gut.
-Did you say I got a gut?
You son of a bitch!
-No!
[ Laughter ]
-Son of a bitch, Jimmy?
-"Why, why, why?!"
-Why would you --
-"Why would you do that to me?"
"Adam Sandler Live,"
your standup tour.
-Yes.
-By the way, you know,
I follow you on the socials
and Instagram.
It is the most amazing,
most fun thing.
And even to look the next day
on your socials
and you go, "What happened?"
You have, like, famous friends
just drop in.
-My friends do come.
All my -- All my buddies
from growing up as a comedian.
-Rob Schneider's very funny.
-"Schneid Man"
comes all the time.
-Chris Rock showed up.
-Kevin James.
-Kevin James. It was just --
-Nealon. Bobcat Gold--
All these guys come,
and they're really fun shows,
and the crowds are really nice.
I'm playing in Philly,
by the way, guys!
I'm playing in Philly.
[ Cheers and applause ]
That's gonna be great.
-But you --
You started doing
these theaters,
and then
now you're doing arenas.
-I know, I know.
It's phenomenal.
We're having the best time.
The crowds are having fun.
We -- I tell jokes.
I play tunes.
And it's really -- it's been
a whole new part of my life.
It's fun.
-More with Adam Sandler
when we come back.
Stick around, everybody!